It worked.
>> What worked?
>> My web app.
I just got my database working, and
I just posted my first picture.
>> Awesome, can I see?
Whoa, that looks pretty cool.
>> Yeah, I'm super excited.
But, most of my friends are using their
phones to view my web app, and so
I was thinking maybe I want to
make a Project COMPASS mobile app.
>> Well, it sounds like your next step
is to get into mobile programming.
By 2020, there will be over
6.1 billion smartphone users.
The majority of the world will have
access to the web through their
mobile phone.
That means there's a huge demand for
mobile programmers.
Specifically iOS programmers and
Android programmers.
What's different about mobile
programmers is that they work closely
with the actual hardware
of mobile phones.
Many mobile apps like Snapchat use
hardware features such as mobile
cameras.
Let's take a look at what
types of problems and
projects mobile programmers work on.
Mobile developers work on projects
such as building apps that
are responsive on different devices.
Creating apps with
a clean user interface so
that it's intuitive and easy to use.
Syncing apps to servers so
that it can present data to a user.
Taking apps from a functional state to a
production ready state through handling
cases, accessibility features,
localization widgets, and libraries.
Building high performance apps by taking
advantage of mobile device hardware
such as cameras and microphones.
The Medium app is a great example
of a well designed mobile app.
It's responsive to
different screen sizes and
there's a clean user interface.
It also syncs with different servers to
get data from websites like Twitter and
other new services.
It also takes advantage of mobile
device hardware such as the camera, so
that users can take pictures and
post them to their Medium blog.
As of July 2015 there are over
3 million mobile apps.
Whether you decide to build an iOS or
an Android app, mobile applications
create a multibillion dollar industry.
Let's chat with Sydney about her
experiences as an iOS developer.